>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
A GREAT PART ABOUT MY JOB IS
INTRODUCING OUR AUDIENCE TOO
YOUNG, GOOD-LOOKING TALENT.
OUR NEXT STAND-UP COMEDIAN IS
NONE OF THAT.
PLEASE WELCOME JOE DeVITO.
[APPLAUSE]
>> HELLO!
HELLO, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI, YES.
YES.
FEEL THE RELIEF FACTOR KICKING
IN.
YOU CAN FEEL IT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS COME UP.
FOLKS, I'LL BE HONEST, I DID NOT
GET INTO SHOW BUSINESS TO BECOME
RICH AND FAMOUS, AND SO FAR,
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED.
[APPLAUSE]
I THINK THAT IS WHY THE WHOLE
JOHNNY DEPP-AMBER HEARD TRIAL
WAS SO GOOD FOR MY SELF-ESTEEM.
I NEEDED TO SEE GOOD LOOKING,
WEALTHY PEOPLE, WHO MADE WORSE
CHOICES THAN I DO.
BECAUSE I HAVE HAD SOME BAD
RELATIONSHIPS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'VE NEVER HAD?
SOMEONE POOP IN MY BED.
EVER.
SO MAYBE I HAVE NEVER KNOWN TRUE
LOVE.
BUT IT GAVE ME A NEW DEFINITION
TO THE WORD "DEAL BREAKER."
AND FOR THE WORDS AMBER ALERT.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
I HAVE NEVER BEEN MARRIED, AND
AT AGE 53, I'M STARTING TO
THINK, MAYBE IT IS ME.
BUT I DO HAVE HOPES AND DREAMS.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE KIDS ONE
DAY, BUT JUST FOR THE ONE DAY.
VERY ANNOYING.
I PLANNED AHEAD.
I FROZE MY SPERM YEARS AGO.
YEAH, YEAH.
AND EVERYONE SAID I WAS CRAZY
BECAUSE I DIDN'T GO TOO, LIKE, A
PLACE.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT WHEN YOU ARE SINGLE OVER A
CERTAIN AGE, YOU HAVE TO BE VERY
DIRECT.
WE HAVE TO BE RIGHT ON THE
MONEY.
I TELL PEOPLE IF YOU'RE OVER 50
AND DATING ONLINE, FIRST WORDS
TO YOUR PROFILE SHOULD BECOME
ALL RIGHT, LOOK.
YOU ARE NO BARGAIN, EITHER.
AND YOU TAKE IT FROM THERE.
I DON'T USE DATING TECHNOLOGY
ANYMORE.
NO MORE APPS, NOTHING.
SOMEONE ASKED ME IF I DO
SEXTING.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA HOW BIG MY
FONT IS?
YOU CAN READ MY TEXTS FROM YOUR
PHONE, OKAY?
I CAN'T SEE -- THEY COME IN ONE
LETTER AT A TIME LIKE A
FAX MACHINE.
THERE IS NOTHING SEXY ABOUT
SQUINTING.
WHAT'S THIS?
AN EVENT FOR HOT SINGLES?
IT SAYS I NEED A SHOT TO PREVENT
SHINGLES.
WELL, EITHER WAY, I WILL SEE YOU
AT WALGREENS.
THAT'S THE DEMO I AM IN NOW,
WHAT I GET UNSOLICITED MEDICAL
ADVICE.
BUT IT JUST SHOWS UP.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER AND I WOULD
SEE THOSE MEDICAL COMMERCIALS, I
WOULD IGNORE THEM.
NOW I'M LIKE, GET A PEN.
I WOULD LIKE MORE INFORMATION.
I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE I DO HAVE
MESOTHELIOMA, I DON'T KNOW.
[APPLAUSE]
DID I WORK IN A NAVAL SHIPYARD
BETWEEN 1932 AND 1946?
IS THAT WHERE I GOT SHINGLES?
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO I AM
ANYMORE.
I'LL TELL YOU WHO I FEEL BAD
FOR.
WOMEN NAMED KAREN.
YOU'VE HAD A ROUGH RUN.
THEY HAVE.
AND SOMETIMES, THEY HAVE
LEGITIMATE ISSUES WITH CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
BUT THEY CAN'T ASK FOR THE
MANAGER.
THE MANAGER IS LIKE, YOUR NAME
IS KAREN?
WHY DON'T YOU TAKE YOUR WEIRD,
BACKWARD MULLET HAIR CUT AND GET
THE HELL OUT OF HERE!
I KNOW THERE'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE
I'VE A FRIEND NAMED KAREN AND
SHE WAS DISTRAUGHT.
SHE SAID TO ME, THIS IS
TERRIBLE.
I LOVE MY NAME AND NOW PEOPLE
USE MY NAME TO MEET AN ANNOYING
WHITE WOMAN.
IT IS UNFAIR AND I DON'T LIKE
IT.
AND I SAID WELL, LOOK AT YOU,
COMP